bella tutti ragazzi minuti questo video
sono poi vj oggi ci siamo dati su matt
father and son tre vesco perché mi hai
fatto questo ma ma che io non ho io son
tratto è stato già così mai perdonare
mai perdonare va bene non lo perdoniamo
però non mi toccare perché sono stufo
del pozzo liberarti volendo non ti
libere io ti vorrei liberare possono
libero teese leggo ma hai visto
se però non mi devi toccare aiuto
liberato sono bravo papà ho invitato
amici a casa che hanno fatto un po di
casino la colpa non è mia
vabbè però mi ha scassato la teca dove
c'è la sta roba e la gemma e maggio
infatti non serve a niente
let's go hai scassato un po di tutto mi
hai ammazzato pure il vecchio no il
vecchio dove il vecchio no mia spasimi
ha spaccato il vecchio rega ma no è
morto spiace non volevo è morto il
vecchio ma dai
senti non è che ti invito a casa mia e
mi fai fuori il nonno mi scusi mio amico
un po vivace un po chi ammazza un po le
persone e non è cattivo ve lo diro giuro
mi spiace un sacco è successo qualcosa
no ha perso la cosa nel cesso
c'è una chiave nel cesso prendila ha
potuto rompere la scatola figo forbici
cosa vuol dire forse in italia non lo so
con queste forse posso prendere la
chiave che sta nel cesso
questa teoria forse molto bene schifo
vabbè ormai la ripresa comunque quindi
lo schifo in mano cioè lo stesso
plastichic bene non solo non ho idea di
che porta parola chiave perché o ci sono
un milione in soccorso di porta e credo
a ok usata la chiave perfetto come non
detto a posto e immagino devi stare
calmo fatti una tisana non rompere i tre
corti a noi per cortese stiamo calmi o
ti sto parlando
niente sono tutte aperte tranne quello
del tizio che si agita ve li devi stare
fermo a zero non devi muoverti lascio un
oggetto però non ci arriva
farmi largo a sinistra il pelato salva
il signor pelato di prima la saluto
potresti non riuscire a tornare indietro
per un po se vai da questa parte vuoi
andarci lo stesso e no perché devo prima
vedere cosa c'è dietro la gabbia e poi
vado
c'è una gabbia fa l'ho vista e quindi
c'è un muro ecco qua salve
oddio atea o che devo stare attento a
schivare la bambola va bene è diventato
un gioco stealth tipo metallica era una
certa molto bene vuota player ma devo
schivarle tutte wow e tipo i team in
pokémon quando deve evitare gli scontri
uguale che sfida incredibile zio ma
questa che porta sta roba qua cioè dove
cosa serve suo posto a ok arrivare
dall'altra parte perfetto trovato la
chiave della cella a per aprire qua a
quel tizio lì
fammi salvare prima di aprire a quel
tizio che lo vedo incazzato quindi non
vorrei mai mi salta addosso salve senta
e tenga pure questo che so non ho capito
senza paura la cig man giorno contento
eto'o liberato mi hai pagato una gemma
graziani le molto gentile
spero ci sia un altro corpo più avanti
perché nessuno non mi scusi però mi
chiudono le porte come faccio io
la smettete di essere così inospitali le
fiamme sono state lasciate accese cosa
che se rotto o c'è un ghostbuster e
vabbè mi chiamo mi devo liberare non
riesco a respirare bene di te che ha
preso vegeta
lasciami andare potresti liberarmi per
cortesia ma la gente che liberato io
tipo nelle celle
tipo quello che era impiccato l'ho
tirato giù non è che mi vengano a dare
una mano insiste situazioni o se fanno i
cazzi loro che non sono mai morti di sto
gioco non sarà di certo adesso che
schiaccia let's be friends il biondone
di prima ma come non ti preoccupare sono
un tuo alleato sì però non c'è il occhio
quindi non ti avvicinare tanto perché un
po di senso me lo fa questa prova vabbè
mi dispiace di averti spaventata prima
magari il mio modo di essere ti ha
sorpreso no io non è per come sei e
allora ti dico la verità non è per come
sei in me ne frega niente che non hai un
occhio i capelli mi disturbano mi
disturbano i capelli non puoi avere più
capelli di me basta non teorico più
smettila contro papa no lo devo salvare
e molla me
ascoltami trasformarmi in verità lei mi
ha chiesto di farlo lei mi ha chiesto
che cosa è successo
ma no ma come gli ha lanciato un
coltellaccio va dai maria hai ucciso il
mio ragazzo grande maria diva la free
hands on di andare devi andare al sicuro
ma non pestarlo a port cristo lo pestano
avendo il presidente fosse così che il
kick it east accoglie chi ti sta
succedendo è morto e l'hanno pestato
ma sì pestiamo ma chi se ne frega non si
muove se preso il coltello ma non può
morire di nuove già morto quindi babe
c'è qualcuno tavolo usa al vento
era un rutto o era il tuo stomaco sera
un rutto complimenti
marco marino non avrebbe fatto di meglio
sei al tuo stomaco
ti capisco hai fame tipo di cucina cosa
vuole signore karl crac il fuoco va e
butta butta dentro che buono vota jsf
questo è il piatto
buon appetito piaciuta prego sono 50
euro e sono andato da me è così ma vado
da un fazzoletto
no no approccio con 50 euro dove chi mi
chiama o cosa me ne faccio io faccio
avere domani vado al ristorante pago i
fazzoletti ma non ho capito questo è
scemo e lunghissimo sociale noi con loro
così lungo che è quello che mi ha
strozzato testa di culo via come fosse
però c'è quanto tempo
niente mi si è bloccato la porta e
profezia verde che ansia di vivere
questo tema strozzato prima e mi scusi
non posso preparare da mangiare perché
c'è un tipo che mi vuole strozzare la
vita mi dà una mano per favore se mi dà
una mano giuro che la cucina qualcosa ma
cagate che devo fà a è sparito è
diventato con l'operato adesso così
random
destra io vado sempre a sinistra
e infatti ho fatto bene perché a
sinistra c'è un'altra bambina sta
che mi copia i vestiti
c'era anche in the witch house sta roba
che devi fare in una stanza uguale
all'altra ve lo ricordate la devo fare
proprio i denti ha quindi posso spingere
su spingo ok manca la lascia al vecchio
non manca niente in teoria ma posso
andare anche salve mi aprì per cortesia
chi è questa una bella statua di una
bambola lika della testa milano perché
mi serve una testa che non ce l'ho mi
dai una testa possibilmente non pelata
no ci sto provando
devo magari devo togliere delle quindi
qua la tolgo da certe parti le tolgo la
certe parti elemento o no perché la
trovo la testa di una bambola ma dai
allora morona da mirizio adami di fiori
pelato dami dei fiori bambola mi
bastavano dei fiori ok la testa
l'abbiamo trovata molto bene
mancano i fiori la lim e mettila che mi
servirebbero di fiori se mi fate la
cortesia di darwin e mutu e poi c'è poi
tagliare le teste ma non puoi tagliare i
fiori con la motosega bo si passò a
riprenderli e basta ok io faccio le cose
complicate non mi piacciono le cose
normali regala nel di fiori ma ho fatto
tutto è un aspetto mettermi così o se si
è cotto il pollo nel forno questi
successi permesso o bene ho risolto un
enigma per avere una stanza piena di
tavoli sporchi di sangue ottimo cosa il
mio diario
state calmi tutti vi ammazzo e ho
dormito cullata tra le braccia di mia
madre
uno scultore a questa è questa mia mamma
questa storica random la nascita mia ho
ucciso un animale per divertimento cosa
e poi la cosa è diventata un hobby
c'erano sempre gatti morti uccelli morti
nella mia stanza mamma impazziva quando
quando si trovava a morte e meredith e
pulisce lei
metti il corpo del gatto morto
nell'armadio per favore grazie mamma
diventata pazza quando si trovava ogni
volta che mi ha mai fuori nascondo i
cosi ok quindi lo spinge la mamma poi
fuori dalle balle
no non è vero gli chiedeva devo dai era
la cosa che devo io devo pulire con
napkin dopo il lavoro fazzoletto
giustamente puliamo la faccia apcom e
finita tua storia e spiega mi sono
scappate o corso via lontano molto
lontano dopo l'oceano la madonna è
notato pure è un sacco è notato vedevo
vedevo fa forio ammazzo ti ammazzo tutti
sono già morti mazzo lei poteva farlo
lui tranquillamente però vabbè potevo
tagliare alberi invece di fare questa
cosa non fa niente andiamo avanti
ecco questo non si fa
questa e cattivissima accoglienza che
successo uccidimi
c'è una nuda non è un proprio nuda ciò
investire brutto addosso ciao ti devo
fare fuori fa male quindi uccidimi
vabbè uccidi non ce ne va bene dai dai
fan lo coco demonio è brutta cosa
dai dai fa da fuori palla fuori
chissenefrega
e morta la fatto fuori davvero
vabbè povera crista finalmente riposo
sempre buio sempre più buio sempre
quanto grossa sta a casa quanto ma che è
al centro della terra che è successo non
posso muovere di più le mie gambe
devo andare a salvare papa papa un mese
viene per terra ma che è successo ciao
hai una bambina se non vedere profumi di
mamma perché profumi di mamma o baci
profondi mamma la quale profumo di mamma
come hai fatto a ri da melo e di mamma
ed è scappato cioè cosa qua non riesco a
raggiungere
vabbè questa scena anche servita non lo
so che starò mai a chiavi della porta
veloce si stanno spaccando la ga mi
spaccano lucio for my son orto porco
demonio
la mia mamma mi hanno ammazzato sono
vedendo la posso decidere di finire la
prima volta che muoio
e la prima volta che muoio da quando
gioco è sta roba qui i ragazzi che sarà
il terzo episodio
spero che vi sia piaciuto come al solito
piaciuto è un argomento mi piace anche
avere sottoscrizione siano sono prestiti
schiette vi e noi ci vediamo l'anno
prossimo mi do da ragazzi
[Musica]